to be a new Nevada head basketball coach
Steve Alford joining us business cards
already printed up yes a lot to do have
you had business cards before early in
my career it seems like those have kind
of gone out of the wayside now so it
does seem identity has really business
cards anymore all right if you were
going to give me the Cliff Notes version
how did you end up at Nevada obviously
being released from UCLA right around
the first of the year into the universe
of the year and having about two and a
half almost three months to really do
some things that I never get to do Dan
I've been doing basketball it seems like
for my whole life and so again you on in
February March is all about basketball
and to be able to I was able to spend
time with the family I was able to see
one of my sons and Lachie League and go
watch him play in person would I would
ever get to took my mom and dad to
Florida in the spring training he's a
huge Cardinal fan up up in the spring
train so to be able to do things like
that
and then to go see about five programs I
went across the country and had a chance
to see about five programs and those
coaches were general generous enough to
show me great hospitality and give me
full access and that so that was fun and
I think just getting that I think
getting that past me and knowing that
okay this was a and I played a lot of
golf so I do get a lot of rounds of golf
in and I think that just gave me the eye
I'm just I love basketball in those
three months was enough to be off so
that it was about finding the right fit
and Doug knew that I like director was
outstanding and just knowing the pattern
and I do a little bit about Nevada
because of my time in the Mountain West
Conference and I'm a small town kid from
Indiana and they're kind of known as a
little big city and it's a lot of truth
to that it's got a lot of big city feel
and yet it's it's not that busy
and it just seem like they're on an
uptick coach Musselman has done a great
job there so going uptick it's a
national program in a league that I've
had success in animation but I really
like the reno/tahoe is
a beautiful area so it just everything
fit very well what advice would you give
your successor Mick Cronin at UCLA
conversation because it's the way our
profession is then that each it it got
better as far as every every job that
you take are you the next guy always has
things a lot bit better and it's just
the way it is I mean I told my dad that
all the time when I'm at Newcastle you
know we the gym seats 10,000 and we sold
it out my last two years so you know you
make all that money then all of a sudden
I leave and I played on tart a rubber
floor and then the guys past me played
on a parquet wood floor and the tennis
courts got lights and the football got
blue stuff and it's just the way it
happens and so I think you know just
like I think we'll be able to do some
things facility wise and staff and staff
salaries that can ring that maybe must
wasn't able to do when he was at Nevada
so it's just that's the nature of it and
I think Mick I think he'll get the
commitment he'll get to some charters on
private planes to recruit and I think to
travel his team they're building an
academic center at UCLA which will be
huge because it's way way way overdue
for that so I think it's got the makings
of it's because it's a special
University dan so I think they're
they're starting to figure out the
commitment that has to take place
because it's a brand that can sell
itself if you're committed to it what is
that feeling like when you're told
now you're being fired yeah you know I
actually you know the tough part about
that was that you know I almost wish I'd
have been told because I found out by by
turning up on ESPN so it's that was a
little bit different that I you know I
that was a tough part and I understand
it's social media and things get out but
I wish that could have been handled when
I had a chance to talk to my team before
they found out that way and talked to my
staff before they found out that way but
it's just the way it went down but it's
uh yeah I don't think it was the
conversation with them in
straighten that really affected me and
it's when you're you know you're going
in to see your team for the last time
and you know you're going in to see the
staff that you love working with for the
last time you know you're not going to
get that opportunity we talked about
that and sport all the time but this is
your one moment it's one team one moment
one chance and now that was gone for me
and that's what it really hits now you
know two weeks later when I'm in Palm
Springs striping it you know that kind
of goes away but when you go home when
does your wife to find out oh that's
different
and I watch yourself watch is you and
the dance like every morning so I hit
the hole about 11 o'clock Pacific time
when I was at I was working I'd always
leave early to beat the traffic so about
11 o'clock he would always call and get
me you know the scoop that's you and
forgive him for the day so I always get
that back Dan Patrick's feeling of this
is the world of sports that you don't
know little job I just sat there in
Washington or wife watching the
interview that I'm doing right now with
you maybe not maybe not because years
particular with the guests you have on a
scale of 1 to 10 how's the jumper the
jumper that scales dropping the free
throw I can still shoot it without
jumping so penny told that at the age of
15 for my Viking shooter without jumping
that's still a high level but I'll still
get out there I'm gonna start some
workouts within the batter guys come on
Wednesday and Thursday and I'm sure it's
a new group so there'll be some
challenges so I've always enjoyed each
new stop these young bucks like the
challenge feel shooting so it should be
a nursing contest you know what I do I
bring the gold medal from 1984 I bring
that first day
just where's ICU jumpers yeah I I you
know have have your hair parted down the
middle and make it seem like it's 1984
Steve Alford walk in there with just
just the gold medal and nothing else
that'll make a statement stay with them
put on some shorts yeah what's what's
your favorite piece of memorabilia you
kept oh wow that's hard I've always
appreciated playing for my dad at
Newcastle Coach died at Indiana my
Olympic experience and then being able
to play obviously the four years in NBA
so those uniforms just as a reminder
I've got nets that I've cut whether it's
been a player as a coach and you know
those things are always fun because you
remember the teams that you are a part
of the gold medal obviously is nice but
those things there's a lot of biblical
truth then because those things are
tarnishing it was 1984 and doesn't quite
have the same goal now that it did in 84
okay clear this up that Michael Jordan
bet you $100 that you wouldn't last all
four years in India and under Bob Knight
after Mike got a chance to play for
coach Knight he thought there's no way
somebody could survive for years true or
false
very true and very true that he has yet
to pay that of course huh I think yeah I
think he's still salty about his last
college game and he just holds that
against me but Wow I did have yet to be
able to collect on I know he's got a new
golf course so if he just let me play
his new golf course down in Florida we
just called even well didn't Dan dockage
shut down Michael Jordan the old story
with all of that so absolutely Dan
Dawkins was he was like that glove
before Payton oh yeah he was he was the
mitten he didn't realize it was it was
being be cooler be called the glove
dockage was the men
hey stay in touch please tell your wife
we said hello and good luck there we'll
be in touch hi buddy
that's a Steve Alford yep Steve Alford
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app